جدل كبير وواسع تشهده بنشاط التواصل في
لبنان من بعد نشر حساب السفاره الامريكيه
في لبنان صورا لتسارع مراحل بناء السفاره
الجديده في منطقه عوكر شمال بيروت مساحه
السفاره الجديده تبلغ نحو 90 الف متر مربع
من المباني ومئه متر مربع من المساحات
المكشوفه طبعا بلغت تكلفه بناء هذه
السفاره مليار دولار وتقوم ببنائها من
جديد بعد اربعين عاما على تفجير مبنى
السفاره القديم عام 83 حقيقه من وقت
انتشار الصور اصبحت الانتقادات عنوانا لها
واستهجن الكثير من اللبنانيين المساحه
الكبيره وضخامه المبنى في بلد صغير
المساحه مثل لبنان فهناك من اعتبر الصور
انها قاعده عسكريه تحت غطاء السفاره وهناك
من انتقد ازاله الغطاء النباتي من المنطقه
في سبيل بناء السفاره الامريكيه لكن ايضا
كانت هناك وجوهات نظر اخرى اعتبرت ان
المبنى الجديد للسفر الامريكيه يعبر عن ما
اعتبره علاقه متينه بين البلدان على كل
نناقش الموضوع ينضم الينا من بيروت صحفي
فاروق يعقوب اهلا بك يا فاروق اولا هذا
تفاعل لاستهجان الكبير مع مساحه السفاره
الامريكيه الجديده في بيروت والبنيه
التحتيه وهيكليتها الى اي مدى هو مبرر
مرحبا اولا هذا الموضوع
المثير للجدل انه كل اللبنانيه بيعرفوا
هذا الموضوع هذا الموضوع جديد علينا يعني
كل الناس بتعرف انه كان مبنى للسفاره
الامريكيه ببيروت عم يتعمر بمبنى كتير
كبير عم يتعمر بمنطقه عوكر واصلا هذا اللي
كان صار في مرحله قبل هذا المبنى كان
المبنى متاخذ قرار تقريبا يتعمر بمنطقه
بعبده
حازمية ماني غلطان وتم وتم اخذ قرار بناء
هذا المبنى بسبب قرب المنطقه لمنطقه
المناطق نفوز
حزب الله يعني هاي الضحيه الجنوبيه فتم
نقله رجع لمنطقه عوكر فهذا الموضوع كلنا
بيعرفوه من زمان يعني منو جديد ليس المثير
للجدل انه هو اول مره السفاره بتفرج عن
هذه الصور للمباني وهذا التوقيت اذا بدك
منه تفصيل يعني اجا اليوم جاي اليوم بالظل
بظل حكي عن تسويه بالمنطقه بيشملوا لبنان
بظل غياب للدور الامريكاني او للرا يعني
برايي كان واضح كتير جدا الرساله اللي
واجهتها السفر الامريكيه انه هي عم تعمر
اكبر سفاره بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط بلبنان
منو التفصيل صغير عم بتقول انه انا هيدا
البلد الي رايي فيه والي دور فيه
ما بصير ما في كنتوا تخطوني بهذا المحل
يعني اذا بدك بس انه هو هذا المبنى مبرر
اخر شيء هيدي السفاره يعني الامريكان
اشتروا الارض من قدام كل العالم يعني
كلنا بنعرف انه السفارات الامريكيه مهمه
بتنعمل بكل الاماكن العالم حسب حجمها بس
طبعا تتعمد يعني بتعمر بتبني بطريقه
مراعي للشروط الامنيه كامله بتعمر مباني
محصنه بتعمر مباني كبيره هاي يعني وين
مكان معروف بهيدي الشروق معروفه هذا
الموضوع لكن صار بالبلد لا يعني في فصيل
بالبلد شوي مقفل السياسيا بسبب بسبب
سياساته وبسبب ما اوصل في البلاد اليوم من
من الرداء المطلقه بالاقتصاد وبالسياسه لا
شيء يتسلى فيه بالبلد عبر عبر انه فتح
جدال حول الموضوع حجم السفاره ودوره وسبب
دوره بالنهايه السفاره موجوده ما بعتقد اي
راي من كل اللبنانيه راح ياثر عليها
للسفاره بوجودها
عندما نتحدث
عن بلد صغير مثل لبنان لا تتجاوز مساحته
11 الف كيلو متر مربع تقام عليه سفاره
يعني مساحتها 210 الاف متر مربع هل
السفاره تحتاج لكل هذه المساحه في بلد
صغير وكل هذه المباني لتقوم بعملها اول
اول شيء السفاره هي منها معموله للبنان هي
صعبه النقطه الارتكاز تبع البناء لبنان
وفيها يعني لو الوضع يمكن اضبط بسوريا ما
بعرف اني حسب الامريكان كيف بشوفوا
الموضوع كانوا عمروها بسوريا او عمروها
بغير محل بس لا بلبنان لانه كمان ما ننسى
نحن فعلا هي السفاره حجمها مثير للجدل
ومثير للتساؤل يعني طبيعه الحال انه حجم
بلد صغير هالقد بده سفاره كبيره بطبيعه
الحال لا ولكن هذه السفاره طبعا لها دور
سياسي بالمنطقه ودور كبير وبعتقد اصلا في
يعني بلبنان في في قاضي عسكريه امريكيه
موجوده بحمات كل العالم تعرفها كمان يعني
منو السر هيدا الموضوع موجودين قدام
العالم بتطلع الطيارات الامريكيه بتحمل
وبتنزل وموجودين وعندهم في في عسكر موجود
يعني هذا كل العالم تعرفوا منه مخبى هذا
الموضوع وبالنهايه كمان ما ننسى هي اقرب
نقطه اقرب نقطه لنفوز لروسي بالمنطقه
بسوريا
هاي السفاره كمان منا منو تفصيل هيدا
الموضوع خربت النهار هذا البلد لبنان مكان
امن للسفاره بهذا الحجم بعتقد يعني كانوا
يعني اكيد امان من باقي الدول براي
الامريكان انا يعني هذا تحليل منه مبني
على اي وقع بس برايي بطبيعه الحال انه في
ارض منا معاديه هالقد للامركان مثل يعني
ينعمل هيدي ونعمل كمان
تفصيل
يعني اقرب يعني الرساله من وراء ان تقوم
السفاره اليوم بتسريب
برجع بقول لك اليوم الافراج عن هذه الصور
المنطقه اللي عم تتعمر فيها السفاره هي
منطقه امنيه بالكامل ما فيك تصوري ما في
حدا يصور حتى يعني اذا انت اذا عم تتجولى
بسيارتي بعربيتك بالسياره ما بتقدر تتجولي
بدون ما يطبوا عليك الامن ان كان الامن
اللبناني ولا الامن الامريكاني يعني
دوريات بصيروا دوريات مشترك الوقت في رصد
موجود يعني حتى ما فيك تطلع درونز تصوري
من فوق الافراج عن هذه الصور من قبل
الامريكان بهذه اللحظه من قبل
هيدي الرساله السياسيه واضحه جدا اليوم
للاخرين نحن موجودين هذا البلد مش موجود
مش مضبوط انه احنا خارج اطار هذا البلد
احنا موجودين وعندنا راي ما بصير شي
بالبلد بيكون احنا موافق شكرا جزيلا من
بيروت يعقوب